[Music]  are you hungry for something good  [Music]  something juicy  are you doing  something beefy  what is going on  [Music]  tada fresh hot burgers sexy burgers lin  what it's summer and sex sells baby  big things are coming for summertina  take off those bulky jeans to be more  aerodynamic oh you're doing it already  great big things like that heat racks  you get sometimes  bigger  stay low follow my lead  come come see  how about what  just the gasp is great thank you like  this  i think we got it that last one was good  okay  not what i was expecting  i'm the marketing department i took  jeans burger suit let out the crotch a  little bit and bam a burger with a  bikini on it oh yeah  i get it no questions from this guy  [Music]  bye